It was on July 2nd, 1776, that the
Continental Congress voted to separate
the 13 colonies from British rule. Yet,
it's on July 4th that we celebrate
Independence Day. Why? Because it was on
that day that the Declaration of
Independence was adopted. Its audience?
Not just the citizens of the 13 states,
but the world at large, what the
Declaration refers to as "decent respect
to the opinions of mankind". It's on July
4th, then, that the revolutionary
principles spelled out in the
declaration first made their public
appearance. Here, for the first time in
history, a nation was resting its
legitimacy on the demands of human
nature and natural equality, and not on
the common blood, language, religion, or
traditions. That is why we celebrate
Independence Day on the 4th. It is the
principles set out in the Declaration
that define this new nation, not, as
Lincoln noted, "a mere change of masters".
July 4th is a day to celebrate America's
birth. It is also the day that Americans
gave birth to a set of ideas that
transformed not only this country but
eventually the world.
Do you think the
Declaration of Independence was written
just for the United States, or for the
world at large? Let us know in your
comments. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.